the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
um i'll i'm gonna ask one more house of
dragon question and i'll leave you guys
alone which is just like george is there
anything specific that you're the most
excited about just right now as we're
sort of sitting in the obviously you
guys are shooting you've seen some stuff
the scripts exist you know where it's
going obviously you've been working on
this thing for a while you're
is there something you're really excited
about
as part of this show other than your own
head
[Laughter]
well yes um you know i've always thought
this this was a cool story it's one i
like uh
so i'm i'm looking forward to seeing it
come alive on screen and of course i'm
looking forward to the dragons uh
you know obviously i love i love the
dragons
and uh we had three of them in uh
in game of thrones but now we got like
17 of them
and uh hopefully they'll they'll each
have their own personalities they'll be
instantly recognizable uh when you when
you see them the colors and
and all of that because the dragons do
have uh
do have personalities uh
in the books and it'll be great to see
that come alive
and the dragon riders um that's that's
all uh
that's all pretty cool
well
stay tuned i mean i think uh i think i
think you're gonna be pretty happy
george we're uh we're working very hard
on all that and uh it's really it's it's
it's deeply exciting it's something that
you know i'm very excited about and my
unders my understanding as an uber fan
is they have some kind of a house right
[Laughter]